herzlich willkommen zur zdf heute live
putins angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine
tobt weiter aber hat putin sich
verschätzt steht seinen krieg gegen die
ukraine vor dem scheitern ein blitzkrieg
oder wie putin es gerne darstellt eine
spezielle militärische eine militärische
spezialeinheit
abläuft davon kann in der tat keine rede
sein es läuft nicht wie geplant der
widerstand der ukraine ist wohl sehr
viel größer als in die russischen
truppen erwartet haben und vielleicht
auch deshalb wird dieser krieg von
russischer seite aus immer brutaler und
zerstörerischer geführt vergangene nacht
ein schlag in einer shopping mall im
westen von kiew die rettungskräfte
finden in den trümmern immer mehr schwer
verletzte zivilisten ein militärisches
ziel war dieses einkaufszentrum nicht
flugkorridore sollten heute aus kiel
hinaus führen angeblich auch aus
mariupol anders als kiew ist die
ukrainische hafenmetropole mariupol von
russischen truppen umzingelt die stadt
wird belagert und bombardiert nun ein
ultimatum der russen unbewaffnete abzug
heute morgen oder neuer beschuss doch
die ukraine lehnten ab mario wird
praktisch dem erdboden gleichgemacht
auch schulen werden geschlossen es gibt
so viele tote dass sie nur notdürftig
begraben werden können auch ganz im
südwesten in der wichtigen ukrainischen
hafenstadt odessa einschläge in
wohnhäuser die verhandlungen zwischen
vertretern der ukraine und russland über
einen waffenstillstand auch heute gingen
sie weiter doch von einer waffenruhe und
erst recht von friedensaussichten kann
heute auch keine rede sein
dieser krieg ist brutal herz schon sich
tausende menschenleben gekostet wie kann
er gestoppt werden wie kann putin
gestoppt werden man streut das
ukrainische
verteidigungsministerium und auch der
ukrainische geheimdienst offen gerüchte
die russische elite würde den sturz
vladimir putins planen gerät mit andré
soll da doch russischer investigativ
journalist kreml kenner und
geheimdienstexperte wir begrüßen ihn in
london schönen guten abend nach london
und herzlichen dank dass sie mit dabei
sind
das ja die
guten abend danke für die einladung er
soll darauf wie festsitzt putin im
sattel
das noch relativ verliert
und ich denke dass momentan tut ihn kaum
was bedrohte hat zwei sicherheitsdienste
der eine und der andere
sind erstens dafür zuständig dass putin
persönlich nichts passiert nichts
zustößt er ist selbst wie wir wissen ja
als früherer geheimdienstler kennt sich
in verschiedenen risiken aus um
behaupten selbst daran dass er 2012 bis
13 anschläge auf sein eigenes leben
bereits überstanden hat also in dieser
hinsicht ist alles sicher für ihn
wir können uns ja soldat auf ja
vielleicht einfach mal gemeinsam einen
facebook post anschauen des ukrainischen
verteidigungsministeriums da heißt es
vergiftung plötzliche krankheit unfall
russische elite erwägt die möglichkeit
putin zu entfernen im umfeld der
russischen geschäfts und politischen
elite entsteht eine gruppe
einflussreicher personen die sich gegen
putins gegen putin widersetzen das ziel
sei es putin so schnell wie möglich von
der macht zu entfernen
den ukraine krieg diesen zerstörerischen
zu beenden weil es eben auch um die
wirtschaftlichen verbindungen zum westen
geht die man wieder herstellen möchte
wie glaubwürdig ist das ganze oder ist
das reine ukrainische propaganda
habe es keinen posten würde
folgendes als wahrheit bezeichnet als
glaubens würdig bezeichnen in den
russischen eliten in der bürokratie und
sogar in den sicherheits instant
schieben alle die schuld für die
katastrophe die zeit abläuft persönlich
auf putin sogar die russischen
geheimdienste haben damit nicht
gerechnet
dass der krieg einer solchen verlauf
annimmt es wurde angenommen und das kann
ich ja selbst nur vermuten aus meinen
gesprächen mit meinen quellen dass die
operation wie in bridge creek verläuft
und nur donezk und lugansk betreffen
wird keiner konnte ahnen dass kia fragt
ob albig und andere grenze städte mit
bombenangriffen werden
man bekommt das gefühl das putin in
seinen plänen sich nur auf
die armee auf das militär und aufs euro
als verteidigungsminister verlassen also
sowohl aus patruschew als vorsitzender
der sicherheitsrates und die elite
versteht jetzt dass durch diese
entscheidung einer einzelnen person sie
in einer miserable situation geraten
sind wie weit die gespräche allerdings
gehen kann ich schwer beurteilen
ja sie haben jetzt schon einige namen
genannt das sind einige der ganz
wichtigen berater in putins nationalen
sicherheitsrat und vielleicht gehen wir
einfach mal ein bisschen hintergrund und
schauen uns mal die fünf wichtigsten
persönlichkeiten aus diesen nationalen
sicherheitsrat an und reden dann gleich
weiter mit ihnen darüber
als chef des russischen sicherheitsrates
koordiniert nikolai patruschew den
gesamten sicherheitsapparat er ist
bekannt für seine feindlichkeit
gegenüber dem westen sein einfluss auf
putin wird als enorm eingeschätzt
sergej schoigu gilt als enger freund
putins der verteidigungsminister gehört
zu den wenigen die schon lange vor putin
wichtige regierungsaufgaben innehatten
er gilt als organisationstalent und ist
ideologisch ganz oft putins linie
viktor subkow ist chef der national
guard ist seine rund 400.000 mann starke
truppe wird vor allem gegen
demonstranten und oppositionelle
eingesetzt nimmt aber auch an den
kämpfen in der ukraine teil er gilt als
uneingeschränkt loyal gegenüber putin
beide kennen sich aus alten kgb zeiten
alexander bortnikow leitet den
inlandsgeheimdienst fsb seine leute
sorgen dafür dass demokratischer
widerstand in russland im keim erstickt
wird betreiben aber auch in früheren
sowjetrepubliken wie etwa der ukraine
spionage
sergej naryschkin leitet den
auslandsgeheimdienst swr einer größeren
öffentlichkeit wurde er vor etwa einem
monat bekannt als putin in einer sitzung
des nationalen sicherheitsrates wie ein
schuljunge vorführte
ja viele haben vielleicht diese szene
noch im kopf am 22 februar wie putin da
den chef des auslandsgeheimdienstes
wirklich abwärts nach allen regeln der
kunst deutlich macht was er hören will
und dass er das wortwörtlich zu sagen
hat und dann ist da dieser chef der das
stottern versucht genau das zu
wiederholen oder zu sagen was putin will
was zeigt diese szene
insgesamt kann man sagen dass dieser
krieg sich von allen früheren kriegen
von putin unterscheidet
zurzeit
greift putin ständig gibt wo den
ständigen der eigenen geheimdienste vor
sie haben das richtig angemerkt er hat
tatsächlich herr närrisch ging
öffentlich ein nie bricht damit hat es
angefangen
zweieinhalb wochen später angefangen
tatsächlich richtiger säuberungen im fsb
durchzuführende und maler noch einige
tage später das war ja letzte woche
wurde bekannt dass stellvertretender
leiter der nationalgarde der
stellvertreter von victor slotosch
auch
expandiert wurden drei personen das ist
ja präsident los also das heißt sie
bestätigen das was man so liest
mindestens zwei hochrangige
geheimdienstler sollen unter hausarrest
stehen laut ukrainischen
sicherheitskreisen sollen sogar generäle
gefeuert worden sein also das ist jetzt
keine ukrainische propaganda sondern das
ist fakt
den fsb betrifft das kann ich bestätigen
das bestätigen meine quellen
jetzt haben sie aber gerade oder werden
ja gerade mit dieser szene von der
richtigen dem chef des
auslandsgeheimdienstes ja gesehen dass
er ja nach sprechen musste was quasi er
glaubte putin von ihm erwartet klingt
alles komisch aber selbständiges denken
und handeln ist was anderes ist das aber
vielleicht auch das problem dass
sämtliche berater in diesen nationalen
sicherheitsrat putin ja gar nicht sagen
was die lage ist und was sie denken und
wie die realität ist sondern nur das
sagen was sie glauben was er gerne hören
möchte
das trifft zu
das ist ja auch das problem
die mir putin hat eine gefestigte
meinung über die situation in der
ukraine oder existiert schon lange
und dabei geht es darum dass die ukraine
überhaupt kein echter start ist ohne
meine selbstständige starke armee ohne
eigene geheimdienste und offensichtlich
hat er daraus geschlussfolgert dass wenn
die russische armee dort eingreift dass
die ukraine ein kartenhaus innerhalb von
wenigen stunden zerfällt und nachgibt
und die russischen aufklärer die
russischen geheimdienste
kommt nicht umhin als dieses bild zu
bestätigen
untermauert und jetzt wird er sicher
wird sich keiner trauen ihm zu
widersprechen aber sie kennen ja den
kreml sie kennen die abläufe wie muss
ich mir das vorstellen vor dem 22 als er
21 und 22 februar als er mit der
anerkennung der souveränität der
unabhängigkeit der beiden volksrepublik
lohans angefangen hat davor da ist der
ganze plan geschmiedet worden auch mit
dem ausmaß der truppen 150 170 tausend
soldaten vor dem ganzen mit wem hat er
sich den wahrscheinlich abgesprochen hat
er den verteidigungsminister zu rate
gezogen hat gesagt sag mir in wifi tagen
können wir die ukraine überrollen und
die ganze ukraine einnehmen oder was
vermuten sie
müssen ganz wenig menschen überhaupt
davon gewusst haben dass putin vor einen
breit angelegten krieg entfesselt viele
meine quellen
haben gemutmaßt dass wir mit einem
ähnlichen angriff zu tun haben wir
hatten wie die nato 1999 in serbien als
mit den flugzeugen die wichtigsten
objekte der infrastruktur zerbombt wurde
belgrad kam auf die studie auf die
straßen und milosevic wurde er von der
macht einfach verdrängt viele meiner
quellen haben vermutet dass es auch ein
szenario für putin wäre
insgesamt wurde offensichtlich angedacht
die ukrainische infrastruktur zur
vernichten selensky zum rücktritt zu
bewegen uns das politische regime und zu
stürzen dass es tatsächlich zu einem
solchen groß welchen krieg kommt müssen
nur ganz wenig personen gewusst haben
deswegen war das um so überraschend für
die eliten und umso ärgerlicher für sie
und letztendlich ist das auch merkwürdig
was innerhalb dieser operation dieses
vorstoßes passiert was militärisch
sinnlos ist
putin scheint ja die wirtschaftlichen
folgen durch die sanktionen des westens
nicht zu interessieren putin scheint ja
der blutzoll russischer soldaten nicht
zu interessieren
aber vielleicht doch die anderen um ihn
herum die sich ja gedanken machen dass
sie ja auch nachteile haben wenn es
wirtschaftlich bergab geht der rubel
nichts mehr wert ist etc etc sie haben
es ja auch schon angedeutet wenn jetzt
ich will noch mal hier auf diesen posten
auf facebook des ukrainischen
verteidigungsministeriums zurückkommen
wenn also ihr da jetzt gemutmaßt wird
ein bestimmter teil der russischen
politischen elite russlands betrachtet
als nachfolger putin den fsb direktor
bortnikow dem wir jetzt eben auch
gesehen haben und ein zeichen dafür
heißt es dass bortnikow kürzlich von
seiten des russischen diktators in memel
ist geraten ist der offizielle grund für
den zusammenbruch des chefs des fsb
fatale berechnungen im krieg gegen die
ukraine
ist das wirklich anzunehmen dass die
elite um putin herum sagt wir sind aber
nicht für diesen blut soll wir sehen
eine große gefährdung in diesen
wirtschaftlichen folgen anders als putin
und das tatsächlich absprachen sind und
sozusagen ein nachfolger tatsächlich
gehandelt wird oder ist das
unrealistisch
dieses bewusstsein dass die
wirtschaftsnationen
schwerst der folge haben werden für das
leben der russischen bürger und für die
elite sind bereits überall zu hören es
wird offen darüber gesprochen
insbesondere in moskau aber das ist noch
nicht
der eigentliche schritt zu einem
anschlag auf butter oder
zu einem umsturz von guten es gibt in
russland auch keine tradition
eines umsturzes
der letzte um gestürzte herrscher
war ja im 19 jahrhundert durch den
aufstand von den gästen der
geheimdienste beschützen putin intensiv
für die geheimdienste selbst ist es sehr
kompliziert etwas geheim so planen die
verschiedenen geheimdienste haben auch
kein vertrauen sich gegenüber
und dieses misstrauen macht es praktisch
unmöglich einer gruppierung entstehen zu
lassen dir diesen
anführer abstürzt also wenn wir noch mal
an die szene da im nationalen
sicherheitsrat denken wo nachricht gehen
eben abgewatscht wurde
würden sie sagen dieser eindruck den man
hat das wenn so ein geheimdienstchef
stottert vor putin zusammen sagt
innerlich dass dann die angst bei jedem
einzelnen so groß ist dass putin also
fest im sattel sitzt und keiner es wagen
wird sich mit irgendeinem zu verbünden
um gegen putin vorzugehen
monitor ich sie daran erinnern dass seit
sieben jahren bereits im land die pure
angst herrscht
es gibt
ständig ja gezielt
punktueller repressalien nicht nur gegen
die opposition nicht nur alexei navalny
sondern auch einzelne vertreter der
eliten deswegen sind viele jetzt ein
säße ich minister gouverneure hoher
staatsbeamter und sogar fsb offiziere
geheimdienstler hinter elitären sehr gut
verstanden dass die risiken einer
solchen widerstand des enorm sind putin
regiert durch die angst in dieser
atmosphäre wird das äußerst schwer sein
ihn umzustürzen
da haben sie hier quasi schon eine
antwort gegeben wir haben ja einige
kommentare und fragen eben auch von
usern riese 1979 schreibe youtube wie
willst du putin absetzen ohne putz ich
glaube das ist nicht möglich aber eben
sie haben beschrieben das eben auch der
putz nicht gerade nahe liegend ist
aufgrund von tradition und die angst die
er verbreitet cyber philips schreiben
über youtube das ist das problem eines
jeden autoritären herrscher bekommt nur
das was ja auch hören will und wenn die
realität komplett anders ausschaut dann
gibt es eben sozusagen diesen frontalen
crash also das was sie gesagt haben er
ist umgeben von leuten die eben das
sagen was er selber glaubt und wenn er
sich selbst zu den besten experten für
die ukraine erhält dann redet da ihm
keiner rein und eine konkrete frage an
sie herr soldat auf andreas ihrig
schreibt über e-mail mich würde
interessieren was die nächste
eskalationsstufe von putin wohl sein
könnte wenn er nicht wie vorgesehen
vorankommt was ja offensichtlich ist
wladimir putin es schon immer dafür
bekannt dass er jede krise versucht
durch eine weitere eskalationsstufe
zu überwinden das war ja nach der meile
eine revolution nachdem ein ausstand in
kiew das war genauso auf der krim
als die sanktionen wegen der grimme auf
ihn zu viel ende hat er versucht ja die
ost ukraine unsicher zu machen und jetzt
sind wir in einem kriegszustand mit der
ukraine weil putin dadurch seine eigenen
probleme die ja mit dem westen hat
versucht zu lösen ich befürchte dass er
tatsächlich
wieder eskalieren wird es gibt immer
wieder ein paar es ausspielen kann es
gab schon vorschläge oder stimmen
das in transnistrien auch eine kleine
sozusagen
unsicherheit entsteht dort leben auch
russen man kann immer noch die karte
ausspielen dass dort die russen
unterdrückt werden es gibt ebenfalls die
möglichkeit
im schwarzen meer
nato kriegsschiffe zu ergreifen es gibt
auch
baltische staaten ebenfalls mit einer
russischsprachigen bevölkerung man kann
sich eine legende einfallen lassen die
ebenfalls dazu führen wird dass dieser
staat angegriffen werden
unzählige möglichkeiten erste nation
aber ich möchte etwas positives nichts
verschweigen es gibt also noch viele
viele stufen bis eventuell atomwaffen
zum einsatz kommen das ist aus meiner
sicht für uns ein gewisser trost es gibt
noch möglichkeiten diesen konflikt
weiter eskalieren
ohne zu atomkraft waffen zu greifen
dann wollen wir sozusagen vielleicht bei
diesen etwas positiven ausblick wenn man
das überhaupt sagen kann vielleicht
einen punkt machen und uns nicht
verschlimmern sie haben deutlich gemacht
dass er ebenso zu sagen ja vielleicht
auch ein verletzter autoritärer
herrscher ist denn der krieg läuft ja
nicht nach seinem plan man hat ja immer
so ein bisschen ich sag mal
der wildnis dieses bild das eben ein
verletztes raubtier gefahr sehr
gefährlich ist weil es dann eben wild um
sich beißt und man könnte ja vielleicht
aussagen putin hat nichts mehr zu
verlieren denn sich zurückzuziehen
waffenstillstand frieden zu schließen zu
sagen nach der plan dass die ukraine
wieder zu einem groß russland gehört das
hat nicht ganz geklappt dann kann er ja
eigentlich nicht da stehen deshalb der
letzte ausblick wie soll es eigentlich
ja wie sehr ist der ausblick eigentlich
für putin eben zurück kann er doch nicht
oder
die schwierigste frage
und diese frage stelle ich mir selbst
jeden tag und darf wie vor habe ich
keine antwort das ist mir unklar wie er
aus dieser situation wieder herauskommt
welcher verträge er auch mit der ukraine
abschießen möge
welcher vereinbarungen er mit seinen ski
treffen würde das führte nicht
automatisch abschaffung senkt sagte
sanktionen rückgang der sanktionen
bedeutet
die großen der großen geschäftsleute
gehen den usa in asien in europa werden
nicht nach russland kommen nicht wieder
kommen im jahre für jahrzehnte wird
dieser zustand so bleiben geschweige
schon der trend zum verlassen des landes
die it fachleute verlassen aller
massenhaft russland das sind
zehntausende sind hunderttausende es ist
für mich unklar wie diese menschen
zurückgeholt werden können und ich kann
mir keine möglichkeit vorstellen wie
putin das als sieg aussah auslegt ich
sehe keine möglichkeit
also war es nicht ganz vermessen
übertrieben und falsch als wir am 24
februar nach putins quasi
kriegserklärung gesagt haben ab heute
ist die welt ist zumindest europa mit
russland eine andere er soldat auf
vielen vielen dank für ihre
einschätzungen vielen dank für die
informationen und auch die einblicke die
sie als kreml kenner eben haben und als
geheimdienstexperte vielen dank grüße
nach london alles gute
vielen dank solange putin fest im sattel
sitzt sein angriffskrieg eben für
solange ihm keiner stoppt so lange gehen
bombardierungen und raketenangriffe in
der ukraine eben auch auf städte auf
zivilisten weiter so lange geht das leid
der menschen weiter auch heute
diese frisch gebackene mutter stillt in
einem käfer bunker ihr drei tage altes
baby sie konnten sich rechtzeitig in
sicherheit bringen bevor die bomben
einschlugen ein einkaufszentrum und ein
angrenzendes hochhausen kiew komplett
zerstört
überwachungskameras filmten den
einschlag bevor helfer hin zu eilen um
so viele menschen wie noch irgend
möglich lebend aus den trümmern zu
retten
so schaut euch an was hier los ist das
ist ein einkaufszentrum freunde schaut
euch diese hölle an
präsident selensky appelliert an die eu
und deutschland
ihr deutschen habt doch macht europa hat
doch macht schließt für russland alle
häfen liefert keine waren mehr an sie
nutzt keine russische energie mehr macht
druck dass russland die ukraine verletzt
die vielen toten es bleibt kaum zeit sie
würde voll zu beerdigen auf dem völlig
zerstörten hauptfriedhof von kiew tragen
soldaten alexander zu grabe weit weg von
seiner familie
wir wollten alexander besonders ehren
weil seine familie im belagerten
mariupol ist wie erreichen sie nicht um
ihnen zu sagen dass ihr sohn tot ist in
kiew und sieben anderen städten sollte
es heute flucht korridore geben für
mario pohl galt das aber wohl nicht hier
begraben sie freunde nachbarn fremde
notdürftig am straßenrand
dabei geht der beschuss unvermindert
weiter
als 80 prozent der wohnungen sollen
zerstört sein nun auch diese schule in
der rund 400 menschen schutz gesucht
haben sollen
beschuss auch in der seehafenstadt
ressort
bei einer friedlichen demonstration rund
um den freiheitsplatz fallen schüsse
granaten explodieren es gibt viele
verletzte und
erstmals wird auch besser angegriffen
russische kriegsschiffe sollen die
hafenstadt am schwarzen meer
bombardieren
26 tage krieg in der ukraine
laut un menschenrechtskommissar sind 925
zivilisten getötet worden in
wirklichkeit ist die zahl der opfer
sicherlich viel höher
wo stets putin mit seinem krieg wir
wollen die militärische lage genauer
betrachten zusammen mit professor carlo
masala politikwissenschaftler und
militärexperte an der universität der
bundeswehr in münchen herr masala
schönen guten abend
fragen sie wie ihr seht immer wieder
bilder von zerstörten russischen konvois
das heißt russische soldaten würden die
fahrzeuge stehen lassen und fliehen
weglaufen ist das alles propaganda der
ukraine oder was ist dran
es ist sicherlich ein teil ist
propaganda der ukraine aber es ist auch
viel dran also wir wissen dass die
russische föderation und das ist sind
mehr oder weniger unabhängige quellen
1400 stück material verloren hat also
das zerstört liegen geblieben oder von
den ukrainern erobert wurde die verluste
sind unheimlich hoch heute jetzt gerade
vor ein paar minuten hat eine russische
zeitung
gelegt berichte aus dem
verteidigungsministerium
die wurden kurz danach wieder vom web
genommen also man muss man mit vorsicht
genießen aber da ist die rede von 10.000
gefallenen russischen soldaten und
16.000 verwundeten russischen soldaten
das ist mehr als die russische
föderation als die sowjetunion in ihrem
afghanistan krieg verloren hat und das
nur in 26 tagen also die operation läuft
nicht gut für die russische föderation
es heißt ja sogar mehrere generäle seien
tötet worden was hören sie da was ist da
dran und was würde das bedeuten
also es sind einige getötet worden wie
viel ist noch nicht klar also man redet
von fünf aber die russische seite
bestätigt nicht von daher wissen wir
nicht genau wo es wirklich fünf waren
das bedeutet jetzt erstmal nicht viel
weil in einer solchen großflächigen
operation werden halt generale auch je
nach militärischer kultur sie an die
vorderste front linie geschoben und sind
damit den gleichen gefahren ausgesetzt
wie normale ich sag jetzt mal normale
soldaten
aber ist zeit ganz einfach nur dass die
russen verluste erleiden die sie selber
nicht einkalkuliert haben in einer höhe
die sie selber nicht erwartet haben was
unter anderem erklärt warum es so viele
probleme mit dieser militärischen
kampagne gibt es gibt sogar konkrete
fragen hier
vw schreibt über youtube weiß jemand
eigentlich wie viele soldaten russland
tatsächlich verloren hat und das haben
sie gerade gesagt was die möglichen
zahlen sind und wieso lässt putin die
einfach liegen und gestattet keine
beerdigung ich glaube so ein paar sind
ja auch wieder zurückgeholt worden da
hat seine militärische eben ehren
gegeben aber wie sieht das überhaupt aus
die bilder sind ja das will ich
ja es ist nicht so ganz klar was mit
diesen gefallenen russischen soldaten
passiert es gibt gerüchte dass die alten
bilder aus
sozusagen aufgebaut und und beerdigt
werden das liegt natürlich daran dass
wenn sie diese body bags wie man das
nennt also die leichensäcke zurück
bekommen sie immer damit rechnen müssen
dass die gesellschaft sich die frage
stellt was machen wir dort eigentlich in
der ukraine und wozu führen wir diesen
krieg und je mehr von diesen
leichensäcken sie bekommen desto mehr
riskieren sie dass der widerstand in der
gesellschaft groß wird also von daher
erklärt sich warum nur wenige von den
gefallenen wohl nach russland zurück
überführt werden und die meisten so die
gerüchte wohl in belarus landen
wir kommen noch mal darauf zurück was
ihr auch gerade gesagt ein generäle an
vorderster front da wird funkverkehr
auch abgehörte sehr hoch interessanter
wo die generäle sind es hat vor einigen
tagen wurde gab es ein video auf twitter
von der ukrainischen seite da sah man
den drohnenangriff auf eine russische
panzer colonia sechste regiment was von
nordosten auf kiew zurollte oder im
kleinen dorf sozusagen nordöstlich von
kiew sind diese panzer attackiert worden
von drohnen und zu dem video wurden die
abgefangenen funksprüche des ruf eines
russischen offiziers der also beklagte
dass der kommandant getötet worden ist
dass das chaos herrscht dass sie von
bayraktar drohnen angegriffen werden das
wurde alles dazu gepackt man konnte
diesen russischen offizier zu hören ist
das nicht unglaublich dass die ukraine
mal eben so den funkverkehr mit höheren
und genau wissen was der russische feind
macht
nein das ist nicht unglaublich weil wir
in den ersten tagen des krieges gelernt
haben dass viele truppenteile und
verschlüsselte kommunikation nutzen also
was sehr erstaunlich ist es ist er
unglaublich dass das auf der russischen
seite passiert nicht verschlüsselte
kommunikation die vom gegner abgehört
werden kann und das ist genau der fall
der passiert ist nach wie man das
herausgefunden hat hat man dann halt
angefangen diese kommunikation abzuhören
und konnte dadurch natürlich
informationen gewinnen über die position
der russischen verbände
also sind das viele fehler eben auch
wenn man unverschlüsselt miteinander
kommuniziert es gab ja auch bilder dass
die panzer liegen geblieben sind das
kettenfahrzeuge liegengeblieben sind lkw
etc dieses sind billige chinesische
reifen ist das wirklich so dass das
material so schlecht ist und dass auch
ein faktor ist warum viele konvois et
cetera liegen bleiben nein also dass mit
diesen chinesischen reifen das war im
zusammenhang mit diesem riesen kontroll
der sich da von russland in die ukraine
geschoben hat und da muss man ganz
einfach sagen da passieren da passiert
natürlich materialverschleiß also das
ist nicht der punkt und das russische
gerät ja es ist ein altes gerät aber die
rosamunde bekannt dafür dass ihr altes
gerät haben das relativ robust war
das sind nicht die großen fehler die
großen fehler liegen darin dass diese
operation und ihre interviewpartner hat
das ja vorher schon gesagt eigentlich
aus eine schnelle operation geplant war
und man dann bestimmte sachen einfach
nicht gemacht hat wenn man der annahme
ist dass man in fünf bis sechs tagen den
osten der ukraine erobern kann
vielleicht kiew einnehmen kann dann
verzichtet man halt auf die logistik
dann hat man halt panzer die mit einem
extra tank ausgestattet werden weil man
glaubt sie fahren die brauchen eh nicht
länger als 45 tage zu fahren und dann
verzögert sich dieser krieg hinaus und
dann bleiben diese panzer ganz einfach
liegen weil sie kein diesel mehr haben
und das ist genau der großen passiert
sie haben keine feldkirchen geliefert
weil 45 tage kommen soldaten halt auch
nur mit sozusagen ihren kleinen rationen
aus dann irgendwann wurde der hunger
groß und es war nichts zu essen da also
haben diese soldaten oftmals die waffen
fallen lassen sind desertiert also es
sind eine ganze reihe von fehlern am
anfang gemacht worden weil die annahme
war man hat eine schnelle operation man
stößt sehr schnell vor man kriegt auch
unterstützung von teilen der
ukrainischen bevölkerung und ist in der
lage innerhalb weniger tage oder
vielleicht innerhalb von einer woche
oder anderthalb wochen seine
militärischen ziele zu erreichen und das
ist nicht passiert und seitdem versuchen
versuch die russische armee diese
probleme in den griff zu bekommen und
kann es aber nur suboptimal weil die
ukrainischen streitkräfte halt immer
wieder vor stoßen immer wieder diese
logistik transporter angreifen und hier
unterbrechungen herbeiführen das ist das
ganze problem dass sich der russischen
armee gestellt wenn man eben den
nachschub konvoi den versorgungskonvoi
mit einer panzerfaust oder wie auch
immer wegfegt und eben keinen sprit mehr
zu den panzer nach vorne kommt dann
bleiben die eben liegen kommen wir
einfach mal auf die lage gucken uns
gemeinsam herr professor matthias sala
eine karte an die einfach mal die
allgemeine situation in der ukraine
zeigt da sehen wir eben wir erinnern uns
es ist ja schon ein monat her den
aufmarsch in belarus im nordosten der
ukraine russland im osten und da ist
schon ein bisschen klar geworden dass es
wohl nicht nur einmarsch in die
unabhängig erklärten volksrepublik schon
jetzt lohans wird sondern sind so ist es
ja auch gekommen eben auch von belarus
von norden her die truppen vorgestoßen
sind von süden auch aber wenn wir uns
diese karte eben anschauen das ist so
wie sie gesagt haben nicht die gesamte
ukraine ist nicht in der hand kirche ist
umkämpft und die fortschritte noch nicht
riesig wo stehen wir jetzt in dem krieg
ist das ein patt kann man sagen wir sind
an einem punkt angekommen wo die ukraine
die russen aufhalten können ist das
jetzt schon ein stellungskrieg wie sehen
sie das als militärexperte
wir kommen möglicherweise in einen
stellungskrieg rein also was wir
beobachten ist das sozusagen wie die
russischen operationen rein defensiver
natur sind das klingt jetzt ein bisschen
komisch für die zuhörerin defensiver
natur heißt sie sind momentan nicht
darauf ausgerichtet zusätzliche
geländegewinne zu machen oder nur sehr
begrenzt sondern sie sind darauf
konzentriert das was gehalten wurde zu
halten teilweise halt die umkämpften
gebiete zu erobern aber nicht weiter
vorzustoßen und wir werden ich glaube
diese woche und die nächste woche werden
entscheidend dafür sein um zu sehen ob
wir wirklich in so eine art
abnutzungskrieg reingeraten in denen im
prinzip mit geländegewinne auf beiden
seiten kaum möglich sind und stellungen
gehalten werden das heißt nicht so zu
sagen dass die kämpfe dann besser werden
also diese pattsituation wie sie es
nennen haben in der regel immer das
potenzial das sie noch brutaler und noch
grausamer werden und das wird die
nächste woche zeigen oder diese woche
zeigen
jetzt war zu hören dass auch die
ukrainische armee einige geländegewinne
hat machen können ist das tatsächlich so
und wenn ja wo
also wir wissen dass die ukrainische
armee vor zwei drei tagen glaube ich im
süden des landes einige geländegewinne
gemacht hat nicht dramatisch aber es
zeigt immerhin dass die ukrainischen
streitkräfte in der lage sind gegen
offensiven durchzuführen das war ja
bislang eher selten der fall dass man am
anfang des krieges der fall wo wir den
ein oder anderen flughafen hatten den
die russen erobert hatten und die
ukrainische armee relativ schnell wieder
zurückerobert hatte aber die ganze zeit
war sie eigentlich damit beschäftigt ihr
territorium zu halten und sich gegen den
russischen angreifer zu verteidigen
jetzt haben wir vor zwei tagen kleinere
gegen offensiven gesehen die sehr zum
erfolg geführt haben ich würde das nicht
überbewerten das heißt nicht dass sich
das blatt zugunsten der ukrainischen
armee wendet aber es zeigt dass diese
armee in der lage ist nicht nur defensiv
sondern auch offensiv operationen im
begrenzten umfang durchzuführen frage
direkt an sie male kilo schreibt hier
auf facebook was wenn belarus ebenfalls
die ukraine angreift wäre das kriegs
entscheiden wenn also auch die
belarussischen truppen die grenze
überschreiten und in die kämpfe
eingreifen
nein das wäre sicherlich nicht
kriegsentscheidend also die bäder
russischen truppen würden im westen der
ukraine operieren vermute ich mal und
sie würden die den russischen truppen
wohl dabei helfen sozusagen kiew zu
ohren oder den versuch zu unternehmen
kiew zu erobern allerdings muss man
sagen dass wir seit beginn des krieges
mit dem gerücht zu tun haben das
belarussische truppen nun jetzt bald in
die ukraine einmarschieren werden um die
russen zu unterstützen das ist bis heute
noch nicht erfolgt erscheint in belarus
keine einigkeit darüber zu geben und so
sehr viele positionen vielleicht auch in
den streitkräften darüber zu geben jetzt
aktiv in diesem konflikt hineingezogen
zu werden
ok damit haben wir diese frage
beantwortet jetzt noch eine andere frage
und da gucken wir uns gemeinsam einfach
noch mal eine karte an so im südosten
mariupol und zwar wenn man sich das
anschaut zwischen der krim und dem osten
also da ist der donbass dann ist danach
sozusagen russland das war ja auch ein
kriegsziel sozusagen eine brücke eine
verbindung herzustellen zwischen der
krim die sozusagen in russischer hand
ist und daneben nennen wir es mal dem
russischen mutterland dass es da eine
direkte landverbindung gibt und die krim
also nicht nur über sie von den russen
erreicht werden kann das scheint ja
diese verbindung erreicht zu sein durch
die russischen truppen die ukraine ist
vom als option mehr das sehen wir da
also erst sich der krimi abgeschnitten
hat also gar keinen zugang mehr ist das
jetzt ein militärischer erfolg ein
strategischer erfolg oder wie ist das
was die russen eben als positives signal
senden zu bewerten na ja das kommt auch
das kriegsziel an also da ein ist der
kriegsziele zwar nie offen formuliert
aber von den meisten vermutet die
schaffung der landbrücke zwischen dem
kreml und dem don was wahr ist das
natürlich ein strategisches ziel dass
man dort erreicht hat also es ist ein
militärischer sieg und ein strategisches
ziel dass man dort erreicht hat wenn man
es jetzt noch schafft er besser zu
erhoben die staatlich untergeschoss aber
es sieht nicht so aus als ob die russen
die stadt wirklich erobern
dann schneidet man zb auch laut ökonomen
die ukraine von 50 bis 60 prozent der in
im und exporte ab also von na ja das
sind wichtige strategische ziele
die die russische föderation hier
erreichen will und erreicht hat und es
kommt noch hinzu dass oder auch noch das
hauptquartier der ukrainischen marine
hat oder das hauptquartier dort sitzt
das wäre dann noch ein anderer punkt wir
haben aber jetzt ja gerade auf der karte
auch gesehen also diese brücke von der
krim bis zum osten die steht außer mario
pohl ist diese großstadt ist umzingelt
wird belagert wird bombardiert was ist
das ziel die bilder sind ja wirklich
grauenhaft ist das ziel jetzt irgendwie
die bevölkerung von einer yuko so
butterweich zu bomben dass sie irgendwie
sagen wir hören auf mit dem krieg oder
was ist das strategisch militärische
ziel dass man eine stadt so platt macht
das strategische militärischen ziel ist
ganz einfach diese stadt zu erobern und
wenn man sie nicht auf und ich sage
jetzt mal klassischen operativen weg
erobern kann dann versucht man sie dem
erdboden gleich zu machen das resultat
wird er selber sein also sozusagen durch
die terrorisierung der zivilbevölkerung
hofft man natürlich dass diese raus geht
aus der stadt man bietet ja auch
korridor an in dem ein oder anderen fall
und dann macht das ja auch keinen sinn
für die ukrainische armee diese stadt
mehr zu verteidigen also wenn die
sozusagen leer von zivilbevölkerung ist
und diese operation weise der russischen
föderation zielt auf eine terrorisierung
der zivilbevölkerung das sind
kriegsverbrechen die dort begangen
werden indem man nicht unterscheidet ob
es jetzt sozusagen militärische
einrichtungen oder zivile einrichtungen
sind ob das jetzt zivilisten oder
militär sind auf die man schießt da geht
es halt einfach nur darum terror zu
vertreiben und infrastruktur zu
zerstören da haben wir ja eben auch
diesen angriff auf den supermarkt
gesehen was man da kein militärisches
ziel ist wir schauen uns in eine andere
karte ein anderes strategisches ziel an
kiew wir erinnern uns in der
kriegserklärung am 24 februar in der
rede putin hat er ja klar gemacht er
möchte nicht irgendwie nur den don was
unter seine kontrolle bringen sondern im
grunde um die ganze ukraine
er möchte dieses regime oder diese
regierung absetzen er spricht von
entnazifizierung etc damit eigentlich
klar gemacht mit seiner rede er möchte
kiew einnehmen um die regierung dort
wegzufegen schauen wir uns die karte an
da gibt es natürlich geländegewinne et
cetera aber immer noch ist ja das ziel
kiew zu umzingeln und die stadt zu
erobern nicht erreicht
hat ich glaube in kiew gibt es zwei
zweieinhalb millionen einwohner einer so
großen stadt wie kiew hat putin gar
nicht die truppen vor ort also um den
ring so eng zu ziehen dass da keiner
raus und keiner rein kann also es wird
keine klassische umzingelung sein aber
er versucht sozusagen die stadt von
allen seiten einzukreisen und mit
schweren artilleriebeschuss um
luftbuchungen
aus gleichen den terror zu machen
menschen aus der stadt zu vertreiben um
es dann einfacher zu haben die zentralen
institutionen der politik und des
militärs in kiew zu erobern das heißt
was wir hier erleben ist momentan ganz
einfach den druck auf kiew auszuüben und
so ganz scheint ja noch nicht klar zu
sein man die operation wirklich beginnt
in kiew weil es konzentriert sich
gegenwärtig noch die vororte aber
letzten endes ist das natürlich auch
also es ist symbolisch es hat aber auch
eine politische bedeutung weil wenn ich
diese armee entscheidend schwächen
bildern sind viele der strukturen dieser
armee der kommandostrukturen sind halt
in kiew
deshalb war ja wie gesagt das ziel ja
wohl auch kiew einzunehmen hat man kiew
hat man diese strukturen zerschlagen hat
man die hauptstadt eingenommen dann
könnte man vielleicht sagen ja dann
zwingt man die ukraine zur kapitulation
ende jetzt ist das nicht geschafft
bisher warum sind die ukraine so
erfolgreich gegen eine so grosse armee
wie gesagt wir haben ja gesehen 150000
170000 der aufmarsch warum ist da dieser
erfolg ist dass allein die moral der
ukrainischen soldaten weil sie ihr
mutterland ihr vaterland verteidigen und
die russen nicht oder sind der andere
gründe auch
also die moral ist natürlich wichtig und
es ist wichtig dass diese armee sieht
dass sie sozusagen im interesse der
bevölkerung der ukraine handelt und von
der bevölkerung der ukraine massiv
unterstützen das ist nicht zu
unterschätzen
diese armee wurde relativ gut
ausgebildet und relativ gut trainiert
von ich sage jetzt mal westlichen
staaten also wir haben es da nicht mit
einer im prinzip dritte welt land zu tun
die beim ersten beschluss
auseinanderfällt aber was natürlich
enorm wichtig es sind die
waffenlieferungen die seitens
europäischer staaten der usa und anderer
staaten in die ukraine erfolgen das sind
waffen die dazu gedacht sind die russen
auf abstand zu halten und das machen sie
auch das sind waffen die verhindern
sollen dass die russische föderation die
luftüberlegenheit bekommt das ist
bislang auch sehr erfolgreich gewesen
also die russische föderation sagt zwar
dass sie die luftüberlegenheit hat aber
das operative bild scheint es nicht
herzugeben
und dann ist es so dass wir von anfang
an der operation also relativ frühzeitig
aus dem weißen haus gehört haben dass
die amerikaner die ukraine mit
aufklärungs bildern rees und
satellitenbildern und aufklärungs
informationen in realtime versorgen das
ist natürlich zentral wenn sie wissen
wollen wo steht der feind wie operiert
wie bewegt dass ich abgehörter
funksprüche haben wir ja schon darüber
geredet das ist alles zentral um
sozusagen zu antizipieren was macht der
gegner als nächstes und ich gehe davon
aus dass auch massive taktische beratung
seitens einiger nato staaten erfolgen
wird und all das zusammengenommen
erklärt sozusagen den bisherigen erfolg
in anführungszeichen der ukrainischen
armee erklärt dass auch dass eben diese
hilfe die waffen des westens irgendwo
funktionieren und einfluss haben erklärt
das denn auch warum die russen die doch
eigentlich die lufthoheit haben müssten
aber die nicht richtig ausspielen können
ja also diese sogenannten maine pads
haben
eine nicht unbeträchtliche zahl
russischer helikopter und ein flugzeug
runtergeholt und dass deswegen muss
russland aus der luft auch vorsichtig
operieren und das ist in der tat also
luftüberlegenheit zu haben ist in jeder
kriegshandlung essentiell damit die
bodentruppen halt sozusagen geschützt
vor luftangriffen weiter vorgehen können
das haben die russen bisher noch nicht
also wie gesagt sie behaupten sie haben
es ich glaube sie haben es noch immer
nicht
das haben die russen bisher noch nicht
hinbekommen und die ganzen maine
pestinger
und so weiter silar wenn sie jetzt in
der ukraine sein sollten die helfen
dabei sozusagen zu verhindern dass die
russische föderation diese
luftüberlegenheit kommt
also eine gute erklärung dass da
sozusagen die lieferungen aus dem westen
mit ja gar nicht mal so allzu großen
waffen doch sehr effektiv sein kann sie
haben es so ein bisschen schon eine
antwort gegeben aber ich will die frage
trotzdem hier weiterleiten von sascha
berninger über facebook warum wird die
zivilbevölkerung in der ukraine so
gnadenlos angegangen müsste es nicht im
interesse teams seien zivile opfer
möglichst zu vermeiden um das land zu
annektieren jetzt haben sie gerade schon
gesagt da ist eben das ziel einfach die
bevölkerung zu terrorisieren
aber das schafft ja nicht gerade die
möglichkeit an das land ja sozusagen
eines tages unter kontrolle zu behalten
es ist meines erachtens auch gar nichts
das ziel der russischen föderation die
gesamte ukraine zu annektieren dafür
haben sie gar nicht die truppen vor ort
das schaffen sie nicht mit 190000 ich
glaube die ukraine ist zweimal so groß
wie die bundesrepublik deutschland hat
43 millionen einwohnerinnen die die
kontrollieren sie nicht mit ihren 170
bis 190 1000 soldaten die die sie in der
ukraine stehen haben die bevölkerung der
ukraine steht mehrheitlich zum also in
der großen mehrheit hinter dem
präsidenten hinter ihren streitkräften
und ist selber sozusagen organisiert in
militär davon
jetzt ist der entscheidende punkt
das sind es ist keine bevölkerung die
eine russische okkupation im osten zum
beispiel begrüßen würde also macht es ja
sinn die zu vertreiben weil ansonsten
haben sie wenn dieser krieg so ausgehen
sollte dass russland dauerhaft teile des
ostens der ukraine hält oder diese
landbrücke dauerhaft hält oder
vielleicht dauerhaft hält wo man ein
großes fragezeichen dran setzen muss
aber dann wollen sie ja nicht in der
bevölkerung haben die sozusagen dann
stand peters in einer art guerillakrieg
übergeht also terrorisieren die diese
bevölkerung vertreiben sie
aus ihren heimatstädten momentan im
westen viele der ukraine wir haben 35
millionen flüchtlinge das trägt ja alles
dazu bei die moral dieser gesellschaft
zu schwächen und darauf zielt es ab also
ist jeder flüchtlings korridor ist jeder
frei links zu gen westen ja und sind
eben 3,2 millionen flüchtlinge die schon
geflohen sind ganz im sinne von putin
wenn ich sie richtig verstehe absolut ja
absolut ich glaube er zielt auch darauf
ab als sekundär effekt dieses krieges so
ziemlich das klingt dass die große
anzahl von flüchtlingen irgendwann mal
in den europäischen gesellschaften zu
einem gesellschaftlichen problem wird
und dass sich dann europäische
gesellschaften dafür aussprechen werden
dass man die ukraine nicht mehr so stark
unterstützen soll damit diese
flüchtlinge irgendwann mal in ihr
heimatland zurück gehen können also das
ist so ein sekundär effekt des krieges
mit dem putin sicherlich auch spielt
also eine bilanz einer analyse wenn wir
sagen wo stehen wir wo steht putin mit
seinem krieg droht er zu scheitern
könnte es scheitern aber die antwort von
ihnen ist klar die nächsten zwei wochen
werden erstmal zeigen ob es zu einem
stellungskrieg kommt und das ist glaube
ich relativ klar aus ihren antworten und
erklärungen dass es nicht morgen und
auch leider nicht übermorgen vorbei ist
herr professor masala vielen vielen dank
grüße nach münchen und bis bald schönen
namen doch ich danke ihnen
ja das war unser zdf heute live zur
frage scheitert putins angriffskrieg
eine klare antwort kann es nicht geben
aber die analyse mit herrn soldaten von
dem massaker hat es doch viele
interessante dinge ergeben wie sicher
sitzt putin im sattel er regiert mit
angst uns das könnte ihm weiterhin auch
im sattel halten und wie sieht es
militärisch aus auch da sieht es nicht
danach aus dass dieser krieg morgen oder
übermorgen vorbei ist vielen dank für
ihr interesse ihnen auch einen schönen
abend noch tschüss unter wiedersehen